สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเนโอเคเป็น
ังไงบ้างครูเรียมเรากลับมาเจอกันนะคะใน
beginner  4 ใช่มยโ beers  4 นะคะช่อง
comprehensible ไทยเนาะอใช่แล้วค่ะเอ๊ะ
ทำไมวันนี้เสียงดังจังเลยนะเสียงครูฟ้า
หรอเรียมว่าเสียงลำโพงเรียมนี่แหละทำไม
เสียงดัง
จังต้องเบาเสียงได้ๆๆลวันนี้เรามาเจอกัน
วันอะไรคะครุณูฟ้าวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวัน
พุธค่ะเหมือนเดิมวันพุธวันพุธวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่
28 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายนโอเค
พ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะโอเคกี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 14 น 11 นโอ
1411 อืเหมยที่บ้านครูฟฝนตกมที่ว่าครู
ฟ้าฝนไม่
ตกไม่ตกเลยอ่ะครูเรียมร้อนงมาคือแบบข้าง
นอกอ่ะร้อนมากเลยนะ
ฟไม่โอเคเลยนะคะมันร้อนบ้านครูเรียมล่ะฝน
ตกไหฝนตกดู
จักดูจไปจากฝนมาใช่เตรียมออกไปกินข้าว
ข้างนอกมาแป๊บนึงแล้วก็กลับเข้ามาฝนตก
อืคนคะเรียมไม่ได้แบบใส่แวกอะไรนะผม
เนี่ยผมเรียบมากผมเรียบมากเหมือนจะไปเป็น
ซุปเปอร์โมเดลแล้ววันเนี้ยใช่ผมเรียบมาก
นะคะเพราะว่าฝนตกใช่มั้ยครูเรียมครูเรียม
ตากฝนมาใช่แล้ววันนี้ตากฝนแต่คิดว่าโอเค
นะตากฝนนิดเดียว
องั้นก็ดีแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวครูเรียมอาจจะต้อง
ไปอาบน้ำใช่ไหมมหลังจากที่สอนเสร็จนะคะ
เพื่อให้โอเคเนาะว่าโดนฝนมันไม่โอเคใช่ม
น้องเรียนใช่ไม่ค่อยโอเคอือ่ะงั้นไม่เป็น
ไรนะคะวันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็มีเรื่องมาเล่า
ให้ครูเรียมแล้วก็นักเรียนฟังก่อนที่ครู
เรียมจะไปอาบน้ำนอนนะเป็นเรื่องนอนเลย
เหรอครูฟ้านอนเลยนอนตอน 14:00 นนอนกลาง
วันไงใช่มยนอนเยอะๆดีนะคะนอนกลางวัน
อืแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยปกติครูฟ้าจะมีนิทาน
ใช่มั้ยคะนักเรียนนิทานซินเดอร์เรลล่า
นิทานสโนไวทนิทานกิมนิทานของฮัน Anderson
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยแต่วันนี้ไม่ใช่นิทานอืไม่
ใช่นิทานแต่ว่าครูฟ้าจะมาเล่นเกมหรอคะไม่
ใช่เกมค่ะครูเรียมเป็นเหมือนเรื่องเล่า
มากกว่าเรื่องเล่าไม่ใช่นิทานแบบมีเจ้า
หญิงมีเจ้าชายไม่
ใช่เป็นเรื่องเล่าที่เกิดขึ้นจริงมั้ยคะ
ครูฟ้าอาจจะเกิดขึ้นจริงค่ะอือเป็นเรื่อง
ผีมั้ยอเกิดข้นไม่ใช่เรื่องผีไม่ใช่เหรอ
เรียมทำไมต้องเดาอ่ะไม่
รู้ให้ครูป๊าเล่าดีกว่าได้ค่ะครูเรียมก็
เดี๋ยวจะเล่าเลยนะคะก็มีเด็กผู้ชายคนนึง
นะคะผู้ชายคนนึงเด็กเด็กผู้ชายหรอไม่ใช่
เด็กแล้วแหละไม่ใช่เด็กะผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ย
ชื่อ
คาที
คาทีอายุประมาณ 20 อืมก็ไม่ได้เด็กมากใช่
ไหมไม่ได้เด็กมากเด็กอืไม่ได้เด็กมากนะ
เค้าทำอะไรคะเนี่ยเอ่อไปเรียนที่ยุโรปนะ
คะยุโรปครูฟ้าไม่บอกว่าประเทศอะไรนะบอก
แค่
ยุโรปอือยู่ในยุโรปนะคะประเทศอะไรไม่รู้
แต่คานทีเนี่ยไปเรียนอยู่ที่ยุโรปอ่า
เรียนเป็นเหมือนเรียน University เนาะ
เรียนๆๆนะคะคาทีเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วเป็นคน
เอเชียอืเป็นคนเอเชียนี่แหละเตรียมว่า
ชื่อคุ้นหูมากเลยอืทาทีเป็นประเทศอะไรไม่
รู้นะแต่อยู่ในเอเชียแล้วก็ไปเรียนที่
ยุโรปคุณครูคาทีก็จะมีคุณครูใช่ไหมมเพราะ
ไปเรียนก็จะมีคุณครูคุณครูคุณครูคุณครูมี
คุณครูคนนึงนะคะชื่อว่าคุณครูเดวิดอ่ะ
เดวิดอืครูเดวิดละกันนะคะหรือว่าไมเคิลดี
นะเไม่ได้บอกชื่อครูไงอ๋ออันนี้เราแบบ
เหมือนสมมติขึ้นมาใช่มยเหมือน a  b อะไร
แบบเนี้ยใช่มิสเ a มิสเ b อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อ่ะคุณครูคนเนี้ยอ่ะชื่อว่ามิสเต a แล้ว
กันมิสเต a นะคะมิสเตอร a เนี่ยเป็นคุณ
ครูของ University ที่สอนอยู่ใน
University เนาะเป็นคุณครูนะคะแล้ว
ก็ครูคนครูคนเนี้ยมิสเตอรเอเเนี่ยไม่ชอบ
คาน
ทีครูฟ้าเล่าให้ฟังได้มคะทำไมถึงไม่ชอบ
ล่ะอืมคือเขาบอกว่าเพราะว่าคาทีเป็นคน
เอเชียอ่ะเนาะแล้วก็อาจจะมีบางคนแบบไม่
ชอบหรือเปล่าว่าก็ไม่รู้ไงไม่ชัวร์นะคะ
อาจจะเพราะว่าคานทีเป็นคือแค่เห็นก็ไม่
ชอบอย่างเงี้ยบอกไม่ชอบเห็นคานทีปุ๊บไม่
ชอบเลย
อืประมาณนั้นไม่ชอบก็โอเคนะไม่ชอบก็ไม่
ต้องคุยด้วยแล้วหรือว่าเขาทำอะไร
มยคือนั่นแหละค่ะมิสเตอร์เอเเนี่ยคุณครู
เนี่ยไม่ชอบคันทีทีนี้เนี่ยมีอยู่ 1 วัน
คาทีก็ไปกินข้าวใช่มยเดินไปกินข้าวนะคะไป
กินข้าวที่ University นี่แหละที่ 1 ก็
กินข้าวกินข้าวคุณครูเนี่ยเห็นคาทีนั่ง
อยู่คนเดียวก็เดินมาแล้วก็จะนั่งอื
อืแล้วคุณครู
ก็ไปนั่งเสร็จแล้วนะคะนั่งอยู่โต๊ะเดียว
กันกับคาทีเนาะตรงนี้มันจะเป็นโต๊ะเป็น
โต๊ะใช่มยอืเป็น
โต๊ะเป็นโต๊ะใหญ่ๆเวลาเรานั่งกินข้าวเรา
ก็ต้องนั่งอยู่บนโต๊ะเนาะนั่งแล้วนั่งบน
เก้าอี้สิไม่ใช่นั่งบนโต๊ะนั่งบนเก้าอี้
อืม
ใช่ใช่แล้วอันนี้โต๊ะนะคะโต๊ะอ่าแล้วก็มี
เก้าอี้ขอบคุณครูเรียมมากค่ะน่ารักมาก
แล้วก็มีคนนั่งอยู่บนเก้าอี้อื
ใช่แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะคุณครูคนนี้เนี่ยก็
พูดกับคาที
ว่าคาน
ทีเธอรู้มยว่าหงส์กับหมากินข้าวด้วยกัน
ไม่
ได้หงส์เนี่ยเป็นสัตว์อย่างนึงนะคะนัก
เรียนจะเป็นเหมือนนกใช่มั้ยหงส์เนี่ยจะมี
ปีกเดี๋ยวคุณพ้าเปิดหงส์ให้ดูนะคะนิดนึง
ส่วน
นักเรียนรู้จักอยู่แล้วใช่หงส์เนี่ยจะ
เป็นแบบเหมือนนกใช่มั้ยใช่เหมือนคล้ายๆนก
ตัวสีขาวๆสวยๆใช่ค่ะซึ่งสวรเลก
บัลเล่เปิดรูปหงส์ให้ดูอันนี้คือหงส์
โอ้โหหงส์ขาวมากเลยอ้อใช่นี่หหงส์อืแล้ว
ก็อาจารย์ก็ยังพูดถึง
หมาหมาเนี่ยโเนี่ยอืขำมากเลยเวลาที่ครู
ฟ้าเห่านะครูฟ้าเห่าใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าเห่า
เหมือนหมาได้นะคะนักเรียนก็คุณครูเนี่ยก็
พูดว่าหงส์กับหมากินข้าวด้วยกันไม่
ได้หมายความว่า
อะไรครูว่าคานทีใช่มั้ยอืว่าคานทีเป็นหมา
นะฮะหรอครูไม่ได้ว่าคาทีเป็นหงส์หรอนั่น
น่ะสิคือคนเอเชียเนี่ยจะคิดว่าหงส์เนี่ย
มันดูแบบดูสูงเนาะแบบอาจจะไม่ใช่แค่
เอเชียหรอกคนหลายๆประเทศนะคะอาจจะคิดหงส์
เนี่ยจะเป็นเหมือนเหมือนแบบสวยใช่มั้ยสวย
แล้วก็สูงเลเวลสูงอ่ะเออส่วนหมาจะแบบ
เลเวลต่ำกว่าอย่างเงี้ยอือือครูก็เลยพูด
แบบนั้นคานทีเนี่ยพอได้ยินคานทีก็ลุก
ขึ้นแล้วก็หยิบจานข้าวคานทีเนี่ยจะไปกิน
ข้าวที่อื่นจะไปกินข้าวที่อื่นเพราะว่า
รู้ว่าครูไม่ชอบตัวเองใช่มยอืคันทีก็เลย
บอกครูว่าผมรู้ครับว่าหงส์กับหมากินข้าว
ด้วยกันไม่
ได้ผมก็เลยจะบินไปกินข้าวที่อื่นสุด
ยอด
คาทีหมายความว่าอะไรนักเรียนผมจะบินไปกิน
ข้าวที่อื่นคือคาทีเนี่ยพูดว่าเค้าเป็น
หงส์ไงเพราะว่าหงส์บินได้ใช่มั้ยใช่ๆบิน
แล้วเอดอก a เอ่อมิสเตเอว่ายังไงคะเอที่
เป็นคุณครูเนี่ยก็
แบบโกรธมากค่ะโกรธแต่ว่าพูดไม่ได้พูดอะไร
เพราะว่าคานทีก็เดินไปเดินออกไปอืมิส a
ก็โกรธนะคะนั่นแหละหลังจากนั้นเนี่ยอะไร
ขึ้นอีกมมิสเตอเอก็ไม่ชอบคานทีไม่ชอบคาน
ทีไม่ชอบมีอยู่ 1
วันก็มิสเอเเนี่ยก็เดินเดินเข้ามาในห้อง
เรียนใช่มยห้องเรียนเก็จะมีนักเรียนนัก
เรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียน
นักเรียนนั่งอยู่แล้วก็มีคานทีนั่งอยู่นะ
คะอืมแล้วมิสเตอร์เอเเนี่ยก็มาสอนสอนอาจ
จะเป็นสอนฟิสิกสหรือว่าเคมีก็ได้เป็นเป็น
คุณครูที่สอนฟิสิกส์สอนเคมีอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยแล้วมิสเตอร์เอก็ถามคานทีว่าคาน
ทีถ้าเกิดมีกล่องอยู่ 2
ใบ
ค่ะกล่องนะคะเป็นอย่างงี้ครูเรียมช่วยวาด
กล่องให้ครูกล่องให้แบบนี้มกล่องใช่ครู
เรียมมีกล่องอย่างนี้เลยนะคะกล่องกล่ถ้า
มีกล่ใ 2
ใบกล่องที่ 1 เนี่ยใส่เงินเอาไว้อืเป็น
กล่องที่มีเงินใช่ม
อืกล่องนี้มีเงินมีเงินกับกล่องที่ 2 มี
ความรู้ความรู้ก็คือเหมือน IQ  EQ อะไร
อย่างเงี้ยเนาะมีความรู้นะคะนักเรียน
เอ่ากล่องที่มีความรู้เนี่ยอาจจะเป็น
กล่องที่แบบว่าคือถ้าเรามีความรู้ก็คือ
เรารู้เรื่องหลายๆเรื่องรู้เรื่องฟิสิกส์
รู้เรื่องเคมีชีวะรู้เรื่องภาษาอังกฤษ
ภาษาไทยเป็นความรู้เป็น EQ  IQ อ่ะคุณครู
ก็ถามคานทีว่าคานทีจะเลือกกล่องที่ 1
หรือว่าเลือกกล่องที่ 2 อือืคานธีก็บอก
ว่าอืคาทีตอบว่าอะไรคะผมเลือกกล่องที่ 1
ครับ
อ๋อกล่องที่มี
เงินคานทีได้บอกเหตุผลมยคะว่าเพราะอะไร
คานทียังไม่ได้บอกเลยค่ะครูเรียมคุณครู
ที่เป็นมิสเ a เนี่ยก็บอกว่าเห็นมั้ยยิ้ม
ถ้าเป็นครูครูจะเลือกกล่องที่ 2 นะครูจะ
เลือก EQ  IQ ครูจะเลือกความรู้อือืคาที
ก็เลยพูด
ว่า
ครับผมเลือกกล่องที่ 1 เพราะว่าผมมีความ
รู้อยู่แล้วผมก็เลยเลือกสิ่งที่ผมไม่
มีอบอกว่านักเรียเข้าใจมยเพราะว่าคาทีเขา
บอกว่าเเนี่ยมีความรู้เมี EQ มีไคิวอยู่
แล้วเก็เลยเลือกกล่องที่ 1 ที่มีเงิน
เพราะว่าเไม่มีเงินอืนั่นหมายความว่าที่
คุณครูเลือกกล่องที่ 1 เอ้ยคุณครูเลือก
กล่องคุณครูเลือกกล่องที่ 2 เพราะว่าครู
ไม่มี EQ กับ IQ ไงูเอเลือก 2
โแล้วครูไม่โกรธเหรอคะครูฟ้าอืโกรธมั้ย
ครูรูก็โกรธค่ะแต่ว่าไม่พูดอะไร
อื
พอวันต่อมาวันพรุ่งนี้ใช่มยผ่านไป 1 วัน
นะคะผ่านไป 1 วันอครูเนี่ยก็มีการเทสมี
การเทสเนาะก็มีข้อสอบข้อสอบข้อสอบเทสก็
คือการสอบนะคะนักเรียนคาที่ีเก็ทำข้อสอบ
ทำๆๆแล้วคาทีก็เก่งมากเพราะว่ามี IQ กับ
EQ ที่ดีนะอืคาทีก็เลยทำข้อสอบถูกหมดได้
A สุดยอดอืได้ A เก่งมากเลยอ่ะใช่ค่ะคุณ
ครูเนี่ยเห็นแล้วก็รู้สึกโกรธทำไมคานที
ถึงทำข้อสอบได้ทำไมถึงฉลาดทำไมเป็นจีเนสู
ธรรมดาครูก็ต้องดีใจสิใช่ถ้าแบบครูฟ้า
เป็นครูใช่มยถ้าครูฟ้ามีให้เทสนักเรียน
เทสภาษาไทยอ่ะมีข้อสอบให้นักเรียนทำและ
ถ้านักเรียนทำถูกทั้งหมดได้ A ครูฟ้าก็จะ
ดีใจใช่มยเออแบบนักเรียนทำ
ได้ทำไมครูถึงโกรธอ่ะมิสเตอเอไม่ชอบคานที
ก็คงไม่ชอบ
อืมมิสเตอร A ที่เป็นคุณครูเนี่ยก็เลย
เขียนนะคะเอ่อมีปากกาใช่มยแล้วก็เขียนใส่
กระดาษของคานทีเขียน
ว่า
โง่โง่ก็เหมือนแบบสิดอะไรเงี้ยเขียนว่า
โง่โง่มันเป็นคำที่ไม่ดีนะคะนักเรียนเป็น
คำพูดที่ไม่ดีมากๆนะคะโง่เหมือนเหมือน
Stupid นักเรียนใช่มยเหมือนกันนะคะคนไทย
ก็เขียนไปว่าโง่แล้วคุณครูก็เขียนคำว่า
โง่เสร็จแล้วก็ส่งคืนให้คาที
อืแล้วังคานธีก็เห็นเห็นแล้วเป็นยังไงคะ
ก็ตกใจทำไมครูทำแบบนี้อแล้วคานี้ก็คิด
แล้วก็เดินไปหาครูอือืทาทีก็บอกครูว่าครู
ครับขอบคุณที่เซ็นชื่อให้ผมแต่ครูไม่ได้
ให้เกรดผมนะครับครูยังไม่ได้เขียนเลยว่า
ผมได้ A เซ็นชื่อแล้วก็เขียนให้ผมด้วยว่า
ผมได้ A คาทีก็พูดแบบนี้ค่ะอนั่นหมายถึง
คานทีเนี่ยกำลังบอกว่าครูเขียนชื่อของตัว
เองลงไปใช่มคำว่าโง่หมายถึงชื่อครูใช่ม
ทำไมครูเซ็นใช่มยเซ็นเซ็นชื่อแล้วต้องให้
เกรดด้วยนะครูยังไม่ได้เขียนเกรด A ให้ผม
เลยคาทีพูดแบบนี้นะคะอูมันเป็นเหมือนการ
แบบด่าก็คือแบบพูดไม่ดีแหละว่าแบบคุณน่ะ
โง่อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อืไม่ดีใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็น
สตอรี่ที่ครูปะเอามาเล่าเห็นมคือคือกำลัง
จะบอกว่าสมมุติว่าคือถ้ามีคนพูดไม่ดีกับ
เราอืมพูดไม่ดีกับเราบางทีเราก็คิดก่อนเ
นักเรียนเราคิดก่อนนะฮะแล้วเราก็
เอ๊ะเราอาจจะโอเคกับคนที่พูดไม่ดีเราอาจ
จะไม่พูดอะไรแต่พอทุกวันทุกวันทุกวัน
เนี่ยเค้าพูดไม่ดีมากๆ 1 วันแล้วก็ไม่
โอเคแล้วเนาะอืทำไมคนนี้พูดๆดๆๆดไม่ดีไม่
ดีไม่ดีกับเราทุกวันเลยนะคะนั่นแหละเราก็
อาจจะต้องพูดกลับพูดกลับแต่มันต้องมี
เทคนิคมั้ยมันต้องมีเทคนิคอกำลังจะบอกให้
แบบเหมือน
แบบเราต้องเครียดเรื่องนี้มั้ยเวลาที่คน
อื่น
พูดครูฟ้าคิดว่าแบบต้องเครียดมั้ยว่าออ
ทำไมเค้าเค้าถึงไม่ชอบเราอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อืฟ้าคิดว่าเราต้องเียนคือจริงๆก็นิดนึง
นะคะครูฟ้าเป็นคน
ที่เครียดมากเวลามีคนไม่ชอบครูฟ้าแต่ครู
ฟ้าก็ต้องเช็คดูว่าทำไมถึงไม่ชอบครูฟ้า
มันต้องมีทำไมใช่มั้ยทำไมล่ะครูฟ้าทำอะไร
ถ้าครูฟ้าทำอะไรที่คนไม่ชอบครูฟ้าก็จะขอ
โทษนะคะขอโทษแต่ถ้าครูฟ้าไม่ได้
ทำครูฟ้าก็ไม่เครียดค่ะเพราะว่าคนไม่ชอบ
เราก็แล้วเราไม่ได้ทำอะไรใช่มั้ยไม่ได้
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยาก็จะไม่ค่อยเครียดนะคะว่า
อาจจะตอบกลับพูดกลับด้วยอืพูดกลับดีหรือ
ไม่ดีพูดกลับดีๆแบบคาทีไงคานทีเนี่ยถ้า
เกิดที่ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอ่านมาเนี่ยคาทีเพูด
ดีนะหมายถึงใช้คำพูดที่ดีเออไม่ใช่คำพูด
แบบเค้าเรียกว่าแบบสำหรับคนที่มี IQ มี EQ
ดีอจะแบบเหมือนนะถ้าเกิดอคดีก็จะเกี่ยว
กับเรื่องอารมณ์เนาะควบคุมอารมณ์ไม่ให้
แบบตัวเองโกรธคนอื่นแล้วไปทำลายไปโชกต่อย
คนเองใช่ค่ะเห็นมยคาทีไม่โกรธเลยที่ครู
ฟ้าเล่าเนี่ยสตอรี่เนี้ยมีแค่คุณครูที่
โกรธอืคุณครูเนี่ยพูดไม่ดีกับคาทีก่อนนะ
แล้วก็โกรธโกรธๆๆแต่คาทีเนี่ยไม่โกรธเลย
อืมก็นี่แหละค่ะนักเรียนมันเป็นเรื่องของ
ความคิดใช่มยแล้วก็เราจะมีเทคนิคการพูด
กลับยังไงอืมก็เป็นสตอที่ดีนะตอนครูฟ้า
อ่านอืรู้สึกว่าอืแล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่าแบบได้
ได้แรงบันดาลใจหรือแบบได้ข้อคิดอะไรจาก
อันนี้แบบอีกมยเกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้อ่ะิม
กำลังคิดิมกำลังคิดว่าเออเอาจริงๆแล้วก็
ไม่ก็ไม่มีใครทำร้ายเราได้นะไม่มีใครแบบ
ทำร้ายเราได้ถึงแม้ว่าเค้าจะพูดหรือว่าทำ
อะไรไม่ดีกับเราถ้าตรงเนี้ยเราแบบอไม่ไม่
คิดไม่คิดไม่แย่กับตัวเองอ่ะใช่ๆค่ะใช่
เหมือนที่ครูบอกว่าอะไรนะเป็นหงส์กับหมา
หงงกับหมาเออใช่คาทีเค้าก็ยังไม่รับเลยนะ
ว่าตัวเองเป็นหมาใช่เค้าก็ยังคิดดีๆกับ
ตัวเองว่าอ้อก็เราเป็นหงส์ไอื
เห็นมั้ยเพราะฉะนั้นเราก็ต้องรักตัวเอง
ก่อนใช่มั้ยคูเรียมต้องคิดดีๆกับตัวเอง
ก่อนนะคะใช่อืแล้วก็อย่างอื่นที่มันไม่ดี
เา้าก็ไม่ได้รับมาเราก็มาคิดว่าตัวเองไม่
ดีนะอืนั่นแหละเคก็เรียมก็เลยคิดว่าเเป็น
คนที่ความคิดเี่ดีแล้วก็แข็งแรงมากไม่ใช่
เกี่ยวกับร่างกายนะแต่เป็นความคิดความคิด
แข็งอะไมากใช่ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็เป็นคนที่ไม่
โกรธด้วยนะคะไม่โกรธด้วยเวลาเราไม่โกรธ
เนี่ยเราจะมีไอคเราจะ EQ เราก็จะเพิ่ม
ขึ้นใช่มยถ้าเราไม่โกรธถ้าโกรธเมื่อไหร่
เนี่ยไกับ E มันจะไม่มีเลยนะคะไม่มีเลยอ
แล้วมันจะมีอะไรคะมันจะมีอารมณ์ไงอารมณ์
โกรธก็จะพูดไม่ดีไม่ดีอารมโกอารมโกรธมัน
มันทำอะไรได้บ้างค่ะอ้ามันก็อาจเวลาโกรธ
เวลาโกรธก็จะพูดไม่ดีพูดไม่คิดใช่มั้ยพูด
ๆๆๆๆแล้วก็ไม่ได้คิดแล้วอาจจะมีการต่อย
ด้วยนะคะมวยไทยไทยบ็อกซิ่งด้วยอาจจะเป็น
การอาจจะเป็นการคิดว่าเหมือนตัวเองโดนทำ
ร้ายอยู่ก็เลยต้องแบบไปทำคนอื่นด้วยให้คน
อื่น
เจ็บใช่มยเคิดว่าแบบนั้นนะเวลาคนที่ทำ
ร้ายคนอื่นเพราะว่าคิดว่าคนอื่นก็ทำร้าย
ตัวเองฉันต้องสู้อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอือือๆๆ
ใช่มนั่นแหละนั่นแหละค่ะก็วันนี้เนาะ
สตอรี่ของวันนี้ที่ครูฟ้าไปอ่านมาแล้วก็
ชอบเอามาอยากเอามาเล่าให้นักเรียนกับครู
เรียมฟังประมาณนี้นะคะแต่ตอนนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าอืใช่
แล้วค่ะเจอกันวิดีโอหน้าค่ะอย่าลืมกดไลค์
กดแชร์กด Subscribe
Subscribe ด้วยนะคะลาไปก่อนค่ะครูฟ้าได้
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวบ๊าย
บาย